hey what's up guys it's Marcus ramallah
here from mkbhd and welcome to another
hardware related video this one is going
to be the full review video of the
unibrow
fireEye a firewire digital digital media
or I'll call it a webcam for now so this
is a basically a full review video of
this webcam to start off with we are
just gonna give you a quick tour around
the hardware of it I mentioned that it
was firewire and that can be proved
quite easily belied this firewire cable
right here 1394 firewire and that will
plug into your 6-pin firewire and your
desktop or your laptop moving right
along on the actual tour of the the
camera itself you can see on this side
there is a firewire plug there it is and
on the other side there is a power and
another 1394 firewire and the reason why
there's a firewire on both sides is ice
so you can actually daisy chain them you
can have a multi camera set up a bunch
of these circled around or in a line and
have a multi camera set up and have them
all connected by that firewire cable I
just showed you so on the front of the
camera is the is the lens of course it
says you know brain and fire eye and on
the front here this you basically twist
it and that will be your focus it's not
an auto focus camera but this light here
will light up when you're recording and
you can you obviously easily twist this
and record depending on the distance
away that your subject is so that's very
convenient that um that it does let you
do that flipping it around here on the
back you have the tripod holder now the
camera that I'm filming us with is on
the tripod so I can't show you the
tripod but basically to take the the
tripod holder off this is how it
connects to your tripod right there to
take it off all you have to do is turn
it sideways and then pull it out the
bottom so I'll just go ahead and do that
and see it so it comes out the bottom it
has basically a circle and a square type
of shape where it connects to the camera
so when you attach the tripod to it you
can go ahead and put the tripod on in
sideways and twist it to be
in place and everything and the night
then he's the neat thing about that is
that you can turn the camera sideways
you can turn it right-side up it really
works pretty well for the setup that
they give you so now on to the the
features of the recording the quality
was quite good the software that it came
with was actually on a CD I showed you
the CD in the unboxing and the city the
instructions were very simple to install
and I basically gave you a few different
options in terms of in terms of
recording quality and file size and
stuff like that
now this can record in 640 by 480 up to
30 frames per second and it does have a
4.3 millimeter focal lens and that's
basically the basic features of this you
can use this as kind of like a security
camera or an actual webcam for something
like a Ustream or a blog TV which I've
been asking you guys about Ustream
versus blog TV but you can basically use
this for a number of different
applications and it'll be just a good
all-around quality economic webcam and
I'll put the link in the description so
you guys can check out more about the
pricing and more about other features of
this camera that I may not mention in
this review due to time constraints
further along the software like I said
earlier was very easy to install you
just pop the disc in the CD drive and it
just it was basically a matter of
clicking Next Next and customizing a few
different options before you got the
fireEye's software there on your
computer and it does work very
flawlessly I have no complaints about
the software for Windows also other
things about this camera I think the
nice thing about it is that it comes
with the tripod the mini tripod as you
can see in some photos in the
description I'll include some photos
I'll probably upload them to Flickr or
something like that but anyway you can
check out those photos and the mini the
mini tripod actually works for a number
of different cameras it's a very sturdy
3-legged tripod goes right underneath
this and you can put it on a table or
something and it'll be a good 5 6 inches
off the ground and you'll get good
quality video and good angles from that
other things about the digital camera
basically the the camera type I like I
said is 1390
or firewire which is the larger six pin
connection so if you don't have a 6-pin
firewire cable
you're gonna mount to make sure you have
a four pin to six pin adapter and on my
laptop my desktop does have six pin but
my laptop actually does not so I'm gonna
have to maybe i'll get a for the blog TV
or the you stream whichever is decided
by the viewers I'll get out some kind of
adapter so I can use this webcam instead
of my built-in we'll see how that goes
other things are that it does have a
software sleep mode and a color bar
generator so this isn't just your
typical webcam this does have a few
features that you might want to check
out if you haven't already bought a
webcam if you don't have one already
other things are that in the software
itself you can choose for this webcam to
shoot in 60 in sorry 30 frames per
second 15 frames per second
seven-and-a-half frames per second and
3.75 frames per second so there's a
large variety of them of qualities and
French second that you can decide to
shoot with with this camera now that's
basically it for you guys I'm glad you
watch this review I did took me a little
while to get the software up and working
but once I did get it in it was pretty
much a flawless installation process I
didn't get any random errors or anything
like that so you're definitely gonna
want to check this out for ease of use
it's a light camera it's made of a
sturdy plastic outer shell and that is
basically it for you guys so thanks for
watching this fire eye webcam review I
hope you liked it and maybe you're
inspired to go check it out in the
description and I'll learn a little bit
more about this camera anyway this has
been Marcus Brownlee from mkbhd thank
you for watching this review video and
tell me if you like the new setup I'm
going to try to sync the mic audio
hopefully there's not too much fading in
and out but I'll try to sync the mic
audio with the video feed so thanks for
watching this video guys have a nice
night peace